[Music]
it's not very do for a comeback
well not I don't mean class snobbery all
that rubbish is at least in England it's
more or less a thing of the past but I
think intellectual snobbery has been
much neglected and I was pleading for
more care about how people express
themselves and more reverence not for
people of high social standing but for
people of you know decent education and
training populism relies on a
sentimental and in fact very old
fashioned view that the uneducated
population knows better in its instincts
than than the over refined elite it's
that leads to anti intellectualism which
is self-destructive for everyone I mean
this is as old as democracy you know
should you get the the ablest and most
intellectually agile leader or should
you get the most average leader this was
discussed in Rome in classical antiquity
and every in every other developed
nation brain has won the battle over
instinct it's ridiculously old-fashioned
to think that there's some core instinct
that is going to be wiser than you know
and then a little analytical and
rational approach I go with my gut you
know that Bush jr. took us into Iraq he
said I I went with my gut watched with
approval by probably the majority of
Americans now every other nation brain
has won over over gut but in America it
still splits the nation and the idea
that
dull Trump has cast off the shackles and
we can go back to being brutes again is
is a terrible prospect telling it like
it is what does that mean I never I
never know what he's going on about when
he says that I tell it like it is and
his supporters say he tells it like it
is tells what like what is in fact since
his mendacity rate is about 80% that the
best of times he's telling it how it
isn't and what that means decoded
telling it like it is is being is being
a blundering loudmouth who gives voice
to sort of low grumble in the common
mind I I can see no virtue in that and
it's profoundly hypocritical because he
his policies do not favor the working
man he's he's a plutocrat to his core
and and those are the policies you're
follow it's an act populism always an
act
[Music]
you